es la firma de un acuerdo histórico un
convenio sobre la frontera marítima
entre Israel y Líbano que permitirán la
lucrativa extracción de gas en altamar
por parte de ambos el pacto fue aprobado
por el gobierno israelí
Este es un logro político no todos los
días un estado enemigo reconoce al
Estado de Israel en un acuerdo escrito
delante de toda la comunidad
internacional no todos los días Estados
Unidos y Francia nos respaldan y ofrecen
garantías de seguridad y económicas para
el acuerdo
una declaración que fue rechazada por el
presidente del Líbano michela aún la
demarcación de la frontera marítima del
sur es un trabajo técnico que no tiene
implicaciones políticas ni efectos que
contradigan la política exterior del
Líbano
el entendimiento ha sido posible tras
una larga mediación de Estados Unidos el
jefe de estado libanés también entregó
una versión firmada a los mediadores
estadounidenses quienes citaron la
importancia del acuerdo para el Líbano
creo que lo importante ahora que hemos
alcanzado Este hito no es solo este hito
sino lo que ocurre a partir de aquí y
realmente creo y espero que esto pueda
ser un punto de inflexión económico en
el Líbano para una nueva era de
inversiones y apoyo continuo para
levantar la economía
la producción de gas natural está
oficialmente en marcha en un yacimiento
de gas de altamar en Cádiz sobre el que
Israel tiene en última instancia todos
los derechos Líbano también los tiene
para explotar y explorar el yacimiento
de Cana más al norte una parte de este
se encuentra en territorio israelí por
lo que esta nación también recibirá
algunos ingresos beirut Espera que este
yacimiento de gas le permita salir de la
crisis económica que actualmente
atraviesa el país Israel quiere
abastecer su mercado interno y aumentar
sus exportaciones